>> Sean: TUCKER, GREAT SHOW.
BRIAN AND FOR TUCKER.
STARTING TONIGHT WITH JOE BIDEN.
DEVELOPMENT ON MULTIPLE FRONTS
AFTER AN EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL
TRIAL PERIOD.
THE VACCINE IS READY TO ENTER
THE FINAL PHASE OF TEXTING
WE WILL HAVE FULL COVERAGE.
THIS IS REMARKABLE, MAYBE BY THE
FALL.
A RECORD-BREAKING PROGRESS.
DR. OZ IS HERE TONIGHT, ALSO
BREAKING TONIGHT, THE 2020
ELECTION HAS NOW OFFICIALLY
CHANGED IN A DRAMATIC AND BIG
WAY.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOW BOWING TO
TAKE ACTION IN AMERICAN CITIES
WITH A WAR LIKE CONDITIONS.
THE BUMBLING BARELY THERE
CORRUPT JOE BIDEN IS NOW
EMBRACING THE MOST RADICAL
SOCIALIST WING OF HIS PARTY.
WE ARE GOING TO EXPLAIN IN
DETAIL HOW THIS IS A SIGN
BETWEEN BERNIE AND AOC AND
SCHUMER AND PELOSI, HE IS
EMBRACING THIS OUT OF WEAKNESS.
I WILL EXPLAIN.
HE IS NOW WILLING TO REDIRECT
FUNDS AWAY FROM THE POLICE.
THAT OF COURSE HAS BECOME THE
ENEMY.
DEFUND LAW ENFORCEMENT, OR
REALLOCATE THE MONEY.
WE ARE GOING TO EXPLAIN THAT
COMING UP TONIGHT IN REPORT.
WE WILL SHOW YOU WHAT THE LATEST
CRINGEWORTHY BLUNDERS FROM THE
BIDEN CAMPAIGN.
SPOILER ALERT, HE NOW THINKS IF
YOU ARE IN THE GREAT STATE OF
ARIZONA, APPARENTLY YOU DON’T
LIVE IN A STATE -- IT’S A CITY.
ACCORDING TO JOE, THE FORGETFUL
ONE PEERED FIRST WE START WITH A
DEVELOPING STORY SURROUNDING A
GARBAGE NEWSPAPER.
WE HAVE AN INFORMATION CRISIS
LIKE WE’VE NEVER HAD IN THIS
COUNTRY BEFORE.
TOILET PAPER TIES, BASICALLY
THAT’S ALL IT’S GOOD FOR.
THEY HAVE BEEN EXPOSED WHAT
AGAIN
THEY ARE FACING A NEW LAWSUIT
FROM LIBERTY UNIVERSITY.
LIBERTY HAS TOLD ME, AND THEY
WILL JOIN US IN JUST A MOMENT,
WHAT IS A POWERFUL DEFAMATION
SUIT FILED EARLIER TODAY.
AT THE UNIVERSITY IS BLASTING
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" FOR
POTENTIALLY FALSE REPORTING.
THIS COMES FROM HYSTERIA
CORONAVIRUS COVERAGE ALLEGING
THAT LIBERTY SUFFERED AN
OUTBREAK WHEN THE SCHOOL
REOPENED ITS CAMPUS AFTER
SPRING BREAK.
ACCORDING TO THIS LAWSUIT, INTO
SEPARATE HEADLINES THE TIMES ALL
BUT ACCUSED LIBERTY OF WILLFULLY
SPREADING THE DEADLY VIRUS.
LIBERTY BRINGS BACK STUDENTS AND
THE CORONAVIRUS, TOO.
AND A UNIVERSITY REOPENED AND
STUDENTS GOT SICK.
THE PAPER EVEN REPORTED THAT
NEARLY 12 STUDENTS BECAME SICK
WITH COBIT OF 19 SYMPTOMS.
IN A SEPARATE
ARTICLE JERRY FALWELL JR.
CREATING HIS OWN PERSONAL VIRAL
HOT SPOT IN REALITY, THE TRUTH
AT THE TIME, ZERO ON-CAMPUS
STUDENTS WERE DIAGNOSED WITH
COVID-19.
NOT A SINGLE ONE.
NOT 12, NOT 11, NOT TEN, NOT ONE
PEERED ZERO.
THE SAME PAPER -- REMEMBER THEY
ARE THE ONES WHO INFAMOUSLY
ACCUSED YOURS TRULY OF KILLING
GRANDMA AND GRANDPA WHEN WE ARE
WAY AHEAD OF THEM, ESPECIALLY,
AND THE REST OF THE MOB AND
WARNING PEOPLE ABOUT THE VIRUS
AND ASYMPTOMATIC PEOPLE THAT
WOULD SPREAD THE VIRUS AND
SUPPORTING THE TRAVEL BAN AFTER
THE FIRST KNOWN CASE OF CORONA.
LET’S LOOK AT THEIR TRACK
RECORD.
IF THEY ARE THE ONES WHO SAYS
WHO SAYS IT’S NOT SAFE TO TRAVEL
TO CHINA.
THEY SAY IT’S UNJUST AND DOESN’T
WORK.
I WONDER HOW MANY PEOPLE TOOK
THAT HER ADVICE AND WHAT
MIGHT’VE HAPPENED WHEN THEY DID.
DON’T FORGET, THE SAME PAPER
WORDS CRITICIZED BY ITS TOP
EDITOR FOR MAKING HORRIBLE
MISTAKES LEFT AND RIGHT, AND OF
COURSE THIS LAWSUIT COMES AT A
TROUBLING TIME FOR THAT PAPER
PEERED AT NEW YORK TIMES NOW
REELING AFTER GETTING CLOBBERED
IN A SCATHING EDITORIAL OF THIS
WEEK BY ANOTHER FORMER TOP
EDITOR.
SHE RECENTLY RESIGNED AFTER
MONTHS OF WORKPLACE HARASSMENT.
HOSTILITY OVER, SHE’S NOT A
CONSERVATIVE, AT BEST I WOULD
SAY CENTRIST VIEWS, WILLING TO
LISTEN TO THE OTHER SIDE OF USE.
THEY ARE CALLING HER A AND A
RACIST AND A LIAR, AND A BIGOT.
OTHERS DEMANDED SHE BE ROOTED
OUT OF THIS ORGANIZATION WHILE
POSTING ACTS MOD’S IN PUBLIC
FORUMS
OUR LOVE TWITTER HAVE BECOME THE
ULTIMATE EDITOR OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WHOSE
CONCERNS HAVE PROFOUNDLY REMOVED
FROM THE LIVES OF MOST PEOPLE.
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF WHAT I CALL,
AND WHY YOU DEFINE MODERN MEDIA
AS A MOB.
THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA MOD IS NOW
99% OF NEWS OUTLETS, MEDIA
OUTLETS, SMEARS, LIES, SLANDER,
LIBEL, DISPARAGEMENT, CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, HOAXES, HERE, THERE,
AND EVERYWHERE.
TRUTH TELLING, NONEXISTENT.
THEY ARE ALL ABOUT ADVANCING THE
FALL STOMACH FAR LEFT RADICAL
SOCIALIST VIEWS OF THE NEW
DEMOCRATIC PARTY
THEY HAVE OUTRIGHT CONTEMPT AND
HATRED FOR ALL THINGS
PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND BUY AWAY
ALL OF HIS IRREDEEMABLE,
DEPLORABLE, WALMART SHOPPING
SUPPORTERS LIKE ME.
FOR THEM, TRUTH, FACTS, REALITY,
NONE OF IT MATTERS.